le reste 24 c'est horrible c'est le
reste 24 heures d'oxygène même pas parce
que les heures passent demain 15h donc
ça fait 19 ou 20 heures d'oxygène et
effectivement il y a eu l'espoir du
bruit mais aujourd'hui plus rien ne dit
que ce sont des bruits émis par un
humain voudrait les retrouver avant midi
ils sont les retours exactement les
retrouver les repérer et les ramener à
la surface donc ça sent très compliqué
effectivement les Français ont un engin
Victor il paraît qu'il les garde-côtes
donc entendu des bruits répétés à
proximité de la zone de recherche il
s'agit de bruit de coup toutes les 30
minutes alors que c'est peut-être humain
qui font ça comme c'est 30 minutes c'est
peut-être un homme mais comme il y a
l'expert français Argelès on dit que si
c'est lui il aurait émis le son comme
d'un SOS il connaît voilà donc c'est des
bruits sourds ça peut être aussi des
bruits de la mer des bruits de dépave
celle du Titanic ou autre donc rien ne
dit là qu'ils ont été repérés il y a
certains experts aussi qui sont moins
d'optimistes et qui considèrent qu'il
est peu probable qu'on puisse entendre
de tel coup étant donné que la coque de
l'appareil est en carbone est pas en
métal absolument et puis là commence les
premières polémiques on s'est aperçu que
dans la société qui a créé ce
submersible en 2018 il y a un homme un
cadre qui avait dit attention au hublot
on n'a pas fait les tests c'est pas
sécurisé moi j'ai peur il a été licencié
donc est-ce que c'est engin était sûr
plus rien ne le dit aujourd'hui alors
justement le grand patron de
l'entreprise qui a conçu le sous-marin
était à son bord elle est même plus loin
disons qu'il était très fier d'être un
inventeur un innovateur sans forcément
suivre les règles c'est ce qu'il dit
vous savez j'ai brisé beaucoup de règles
pour en arriver là et je les ai brisés
grâce à ma logique et une bonne
connaissance de l'ingénierie le titane
et la fibre de carbone on nous avait
conseillé de pas le faire et ben moi je
l'ai fait parce que il y a une vidéo
assez folle qui ressort depuis le drame
la visite du sous-marin ce que vous nous
disiez Gilles et vous allez voir que
certains éléments ne sont pas très
rassurants notamment ce qui sert à
piloter le sous-marin
de contrôle ici le sonar juste là et
tout ça ce pilote avec cette simple
manette de jeux vidéo et cet écran
tactile donc si vous voulez avancer vous
appuyez là pour aller en arrière vous
faites comme ça pour tourner à gauche
tourner à droite monter descendre et
c'est en Bluetooth donc je peux la filer
à n'importe qui c'est fait pour les ados
donc c'est super résistant mais on en a
plusieurs à bord au cas où
il y a eu le témoignage de du producteur
des Simpson ce qui a fait ce voyage
l'année dernière qui dit que d'abord il
faut signer une décharge avec le mot
mort trois fois dans le dans le contrat
consigne donc pour vous dire le danger
et il dit que c'est horrible à
l'intérieur parce qu'en fait la
communication coupe tout le temps ils
sont complètement sur chinois et il y a
des instructions je ne sais pas s'ils
vont les suivre mais je pense que oui il
faut qu'il reste couché pour prendre le
moins d'oxygène possible il fait très
froid donc soit couché avec des
couvertures de survie ça doit être
l'enfer enfin moi je vraiment
humainement c'est pas envoyé on peut pas
envoyer de bouteilles d'oxygène sous
l'eau parce que c'est trop profond 4000
mètres donc c'est vrai que la question
de est-ce que ce drame était anticipable
elle se pose parce que c'était vraiment
pas raisonnable de le faire le
sous-marin il est minuscule on peut même
pas envoyer d'oxygène donc c'est vrai
que c'est c'est surréaliste quoi alors
pour comprendre ce que doivent ressentir
les passagers dans un cas aussi
dramatique un ancien reporter américain
raconté le jour où il a cru mourir lors
d'une expédition sur les papes du
Titanic en 2000 regardez le Titanic a
coulé et il s'est brisé en deux morceaux
donc nous passions au-dessus de ses
débris et nous nous approchons de la
poupe et là je me suis rendu compte que
nous accélérions en même temps que nous
nous approchons de l'hélice nous allions
effectivement de plus en plus vite et là
j'ai pensé que ce n'était pas normal
nous étions coincés dans un sous-marin
en pleine vitesse qui nous a propulsé
contre l'hélice du bateau on s'était
fait prendre derrière les lames je
pensais que je n'allais pas me sortir de
là
heureusement notre pilote était très
expérimenté il a fait en sorte qu'on
s'en sorte mais même après ça ce n'était
pas fini pour nous parce qu'il nous a
fallu encore 2h30 pour remonter à la
surface c'était très dangereux ce n'est
pas une attraction Disneyland alors
c'est une expédition qui a un coup
puisqu'il faut débosser plus de 250 000
dollars pour y participer à dure
normalement 8 jours c'est pas la
première expédition puisque la société
organise ce type d'expédition depuis 2
ans Gilles c'est un truc de fou 250 000
euros c'est incroyable c'est les
privilégiés alors là il y a le pilote
donc
le pilote avec sa manette de jeux vidéo
que vous avez montré il y a un arjolet
l'expert français il y a un milliardaire
anglais qui fait des voilà un
explorateur qui fait d'autres
expéditions et il y a un monsieur très
riche du Pakistan qui est là avec son
fils voilà et il craignent tout à fait
légitimement dans ces cas-là il faut
effectivement dépenser le moins
d'oxygène donc il compte on se dit que
peut-être marjolais qui est expert va
leur expliquer comment dépenser moins
d'oxygène mais ils ont peur que le papa
et l'ado est légitimement soient
terrifié l'un pour l'autre et que
peut-être l'Oxy viennent à manquer plus
rapidement que les 19 heures voilà ce
qui est dommage justement Paula c'est le
grand expert du Titanic il a 77 ans il
est passionné d'archéologie maritime il
a été un des tout premiers hommes à
descendre voir les papes du Titanic en
87 et on va rappeler qu'il voulait pas y
aller oui il avait peur en fait c'est
comme si cette expédition était un peu
maudite avait-il senti cette il laissait
entraîner et lui qui a l'intuition de de
tout ça on a eu l'impression qu'il y
allait à contrecoeur dans cette
expédition et c'était le hublot
justement qui lui semblait trop fragile
et il avait peur d'aller dans ce il l'a
dit vraiment il a il avait peur d'aller
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas eu des
pressions parce que comme c'est le
spécialiste mondial et que ça coûte très
cher est-ce que c'était pas un peu
l'attraction de l'avoir est-ce qu'il a
pas eu les pressions du problème
non mais si c'était un peu voilà si si
c'est senti obligé parce que peut-être
qu'il y a des contrats avec
la conscience scientifique n'est pas
intéressé mais c'est c'est exactement la
question
et on est obligé de faire des recherches
évidemment parce que on doit tout entier
jusqu'au bout mais les experts sont très
pessimistes parce que les taux de
flottabilité positive c'est-à-dire que
même quand tous les systèmes s'arrêtent
il y a plus d'électricité les moteurs
s'arrêtent tout il remonte
automatiquement la surface comme un
bouchon et ça s'il reste au fond que les
parenthèses surface c'est qu'il y a une
voix d'eau et c'est une voix d'eau
évidemment tout est foutu quoi donc là
ils sont obligés de leur chercher bah si
ils viennent que sur le temps la réserve
d'oxygène mais il y a très peu de
chances qu'il les retrouve mais c'est
bah non non non non non non non il
remontait automatiquement il est conçu
comme ça c'est pour ça que les paroles
liés par un cas parce que à 4000 mètres
de profondeur c'est très facile de
mettre un câble qui le relie au bateau
de 4000 m sauf que comme il est censé
remonter tout seul il y a pas besoin de
mettre de câble et il remonte pas donc
il y a un problème